that was just a scary scene to see um  like I said even if it wasn't my family  member but for it to be my nephew it was  just that much more gut-wrenching to to  see that  [Music]  we went from trying to console his  little brother to the whole living room  was crying we were all in tears  [Music]  foreign  T went out twice went out on the field  when they resuscitated them and then  when he got back to the hospital went  out a second time and they had to hit  him with the defibrillator  [Music]  people don't even know us are showing  love and support man and we're so  thankful for that I know those prayers  is helping because he's definitely  recovering God got a mission for him and  that's why he's still here Glenn and  many family members flew to Cincinnati  to support Hamlin in his recovery the  family did release a statement saying  they are deeply moved by the prayers  kind words and donations that have  flooded in from fans across the country